[Music]
how's everyone doing today hey um first
of all thank you so much for coming in
this morning to our studio before we get
started I have a lot of questions for
you guys the only reason we get to be
here at the Toronto Film Festival is
because of our sponsors and I want to
give a huge thank you to Nordstrom
Canada for allowing us to cover your
movie and all the other movies so a big
THANK YOU now I get to talk to you guys
everyone watching this interview except
for a few people will not have seen the
movie I hate asking the generic
questions but can you sort of talk about
what the film is about all right
the film was about a queer black
teenager that wakes up every day and got
shot by the police on their way to his
closet of my boyfriend's house to come
out to a conservative pundit dad and I
think it it really deals a lot was just
identity and accepting people as whole
rather than in fragments all day I think
it's a film really about identity you
know who we are who we can be in this
life and how we can make that work for
ourselves and it's told through the
perspective of this young black gay teen
who is in love with a young white guy
who has a beard
friend in this white girl and ultimately
all sitting here right all sitting here
and it's just uh you know what does he
have to do to get through a day and move
on with his life
I got so I got to tell you I've seen the
film one of the things that struck me
was right at the beginning I I I try not
to when you see movies of festivals the
greatest advantage is you don't you
haven't seen a trailer you don't know
the twists and turns so as I was
watching it something it's a pretty
powerful opening when there's this is I
don't want to give how much are you am I
allowed to say you know we can dance
around it we'll find a way to weave
around what happens you know this thing
that is very powerful opening 15 minutes
yes I think that's the best way to say
for you guys I want to add for you guys
what was it like reading the script for
the first time and because this is not
your typical narrative structure and
story yeah for me personally I think
that's the first thing that stood out
because
for young black actors we don't
typically get to do projects that have a
time-loop structure so when I read that
I was already blown away and then with
the content of it as well I was like oh
yeah this is this is something that
needs to be seen
thanks man I always say this it's like I
read it too fast because I mean Stan Lee
wrote such a beautiful story and I just
wanted to know what happened next I
never expected anything to happen I was
in the moment when I was reading it the
whole time and he wrote such beautiful
full characters so he made it like easy
for us because there wasn't much
guessing it was all it was mostly on the
page and and I mean he just wrote such a
beautiful script Spencer you have to
talk yeah I mean I think we all read
quite a few scripts and they don't
usually come along and have these kind
of well ideas and characters and well
let's be honest a lot of them are [ __ ]
[Laughter]
maybe we should not let Spencer you know
by the way you're not the only actor
I've heard say that they don't read like
the great scripts are hard to come by
yeah I hear that for truth you just
don't get that and especially from a 19
year old kid at the time you know it was
it was incredible and yeah I was just
happy to be able to get to go in and
read for it you know sure for for all of
you guys no matter what no matter what
movie you're making you never have
enough time and you never have enough
money so when you started to make this
thing for each of you what were you sort
of nervous to be able to pull off with
the time and money that you had I knew
that we had exactly enough time and
precisely enough money to do everything
we needed to do to land right here it
all worked out exactly as we planned
you're wrong okay you know the real
challenge of of the time and all you
know all the things that come with film
was just making sure that we had synergy
and that we were a family before we got
to set that was the real difficulty and
it worked out well you know I mean for
me just because the sort of work that
I've done in in television you know
you're always dealing with the schedule
you're always dealing with the tight
budget so it's kind of a training camp
you know for a production where you
don't have all the resources that you'd
like or need and there's a ticking clock
what helped us out in terms of
production is because it was a loop
structure that removed some of the work
of having to you know go through scene
by scene by scene and create new things
for every cycle although as we move
through the structure of the film we
advance the story by certain degrees but
you know everybody's still wearing the
same clothes so I mean most things make
things a little bit easy it's a
challenge but if you put your brains
together and really map out a plan as to
how you're gonna do it it doesn't work
out exactly but you can get pretty close
and I think we did actually gonna flip
the question for you guys because I just
realized you're probably filming
different structures of the time loop
maybe on the same day so what is it like
as actors trying to get your head around
the multiple versions of what you're
doing because you're filming on those
certain sets painful painful um it was
pretty tough keeping up with the time
loops because not only do we have to try
to navigate it in our own brains but we
have to make sure that we are painting
the picture for the audience so at any
given time you know we weren't shooting
in sequence so at one point we could be
at the climax of the film and then the
very next scene the same day it could be
the loop one where you know you're in a
completely different mindset we have a
completely different relationship we
have a completely different
relationships and so those things were
over overlapping every single day so
thank God for script supervisors
shout-out to them we need you
Holle shoutout and and Olli kept it
straight to I mean well I mean like the
little details for these guys it's like
when you're trying to build a
performance you know it's trying to make
sure that you start out at a place that
you can know alright here's my ground
zero right and and when you're at
something that's climactic or a big
moment you know you try to make it big
enough so it has enough distance
emotionally you know and performance
wise from where you started but you also
don't want it so far that it can't be
gotten to in the course of you know how
the story is structured how the story
flows Steven did an amazing job with
that he is I'm incredibly impressed by
sort of like his micro emotions like
he's able to convey a lot with a little
it's a film you have to pay attention to
no we don't spoon feed you anything you
know we're not we honestly don't help
and that also helped in terms of the way
it plays out because even the big
moments in a manner of speaking are kind
of small and that I think allowed him to
build a performance there was nuanced
but consistent and I think it kind of
gave a gauge to his other actors as well
yeah because a lot of my performance was
based on how because I didn't know how
he was gonna be within each loop you
know I can read it and anticipate all I
want but there was RIT was really like
almost an improv and improvisational
feel to a lot of the scenes because
we're shooting the same scene six
different ways kind of thing and little
things are changing in each one little
details again like an acting exercise
you know have you ever been to a camp
and they give you the same bones and
then you kind of have to play with it
differently so I feel also I mean for me
I learned so much by doing that and it
as an actor it needs you you had your
structure to the scene but also it gave
you this freedom to kind of explore the
character which I thought was was so fun
and
I am so serious when I say I have so
many other questions for you guys but I
have to stop because of [ __ ] nature
of our studio but hopefully I'll be able
to talk to you guys again down the road
about this because I have a list I'm
just gonna say seriously congrats on the
movie and congrats and be part of the
Toronto International Film Festival
which is my favorite festival on the
planet and such a great place for movies
I hope you have a great experience thank
you so much for coming in thank you
idiot